ce soir on va lancer un site qui
s'appelle calculatrice pour un Québec
solidaire.net les gens vont pouvoir voir
c'est quoi l'impact du plan de Québec
solidaire ce qui vont découvrir c'est
comme dans la très grande majorité des
cas on va baisser leur facture on va
améliorer leurs qualités de vie est-ce
que la calculatrice de Québec solidaire
donne des résultats qui sont juste
non c'est un outil qui manque de
précision
la calculatrice de QS est en quelque
sorte un questionnaire on vous demande
quels sont vos revenus le montant de vos
actifs si vous attendez une place en CPE
etc au bout de la démarche on vous
indique quelle serait l'impact financier
des mesures proposées par la formation
politique mais dans certains cas la
calculatrice s'applique les mêmes
montants pour tout le monde alors qu'il
devrait plutôt varier c'est le cas pour
le congé de TVQ sur les biens essentiels
peu importe les revenus d'une personne
on indique que ça va générer 550 dollars
d'épargne par année dans les faits ce
serait plus bas pour les gens à faible
revenu qui dépassent moins et plus élevé
pour les gens plus riches qui peuvent
dépenser davantage selon la calculatrice
de QS une famille qui aurait une place
en CPE plutôt qu'en garderie privée non
subventionnée épargnerait 2366 dollars
par année
mais les calculs sont établi en fonction
d'un ménage qui gagne 100 000 dollars
par année et qui paye 50 dollars par
jour pour sa place en garderie l'impact
serait beaucoup moins grand pour une
famille qui gagne 50000 dollars par
année parce qu'elle bénéficie
actuellement d'un crédit d'impôt plus
généreux pour ses frais de garde le
montant épargné serait plutôt de 767
dollars il faut cliquer sur un lien à la
toute fin de l'exercice pour comprendre
comment cuisses effectue ses calculs le
parti reconnaît que les montants
pourraient varier selon les situations
personnelles de chacun selon les
fiscalistes que nous avons consulté
l'outil ne devrait pas être présenté
comme une calculatrice